[Music]
climate dark time your witness Raymond
officially by the grace of God and when
they believe that it's nights of America
I take possession of this planet even
before the days of sci-fi Saturday
matinee movies like the one you saw
there traveling to the moon has been a
dream throughout much of human history
and the idea of one day visiting the
object we all see in the sky has
inspired art throughout the ages now a
new exhibit inspired by the Apollo 11
anniversary is showcasing images from
the whimsical to the scientific this
week we got a chance to visit this is a
lunar atlas that was created at the
Paris observatory at the start of the
last century the race to photograph the
moon led to this the world's first
photographic atlas of the lunar surface
published by two French astronomers in
1910 it's part of a new exhibition New
York's Metropolitan Museum of Art called
Apollo's muse the moon in the age of
photography mia Fineman is the curator
we began with Galileo he in 1610 he
published a book called Siderius nuncius
or a starry messenger and that was the
first drawing and description of the
moon as seen through a telescope
Galileo's depictions revolutionised
scientific and cultural thought about
the moon no longer was it the
unblemished lunar or above Greek
mythology but instead a world of its own
with a landscape of craters mountains
and valleys more than 200 years later
the invention of photography deepened
our knowledge and understanding of the
moon these are some of the earliest
surviving degorio types with cameras
that required 30 minutes to capture an
image the scientists had to sit there
you know with the camera for 30 minutes
but he also had to move the telescope
because remember the moon is moving
across the sky so in 30 minutes it's
gonna move a little bit and so you need
to keep in order to keep it in focus you
need to move the telescope
together the pieces layout the
intersection of science art and popular
culture
this Italian lithograph pays homage to
moon mania 1830 style that's when
satirical articles in the New York Sun
claimed that scientists using powerful
telescopes had spotted life on the moon
including tiny animals and humanoid
creatures readers believed the stories
were real it was known as the grant moon
hoax but it was really intended as a
satire except that it was so well done
that nobody it was it fooled everybody
at the turn of the century posing with
lunar cardboard cutouts was all the rage
the closest humans would get to the moon
until that moment also presented in the
exhibit the moon landing 50 years ago
today what is it about the moon that you
think has so captivated artists and
photographers well the moon is a paradox
it's always there it's always present
but it's always changing some nights we
see it some nights we don't it's close
and yet it's always out of reach so it's
sort of this it's it's a real symbol of
desire of you know this is this
melancholy and longing you know for
something that we can't quite reach